le cabinet allait me what devenu
l'administrateur provisoire du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais début juin
suite on le rappelle à cette action en
justice d'un groupe de militants
mécontents du fonctionnement du parti et
de la non tenue d'assemblées générales
depuis 2011 bonjour à l'animateur votre
cabinet avait la charge d'organiser
l'assemblée générale du mime vendredi
dernier sauf qu'il s'est passé a rien
rien ce n'est cette violente montée
d'adrénaline dans les deux camps que
s'est il passé
égoutter une explication sur ce qui
s'est passé mais j'ai demandé à ceux qui
sont à l'origine du désordre que vous
avez évoquées je sais que parmi les
arguments qui ont été avancés figurent
le problème de la liste
le collège lettre le collège électoral à
la fois dans sa composition mais aussi
parce que la liste qui fixait un peu les
flots graphie de ceux de ce collège nous
a pas été communiqué disons une nous et
été communiquée plus une heure avant la
tenue de l'assemblée
alors voilà alors comme expliquer cela à
partir du moment où vous avez fixé la
date de cette assemblée générale c'était
vendredi dernier c'est que vous aviez
fixé les règles de tenue de cette
assemblée générale j'imagine en
concertation avec les deux parties en
présence et si que leurs conseils tendez
voilà c'est déjà profit que c'est le
collège électoral c'est au liban n'était
mené que cette passe était pas quelque
chose de facile compte tenu du fait
qu'il n'ya pas eu d'élection depuis
quand même de 2011 est donc dans un
premier temps où s'est organisé pour
fixer la liste ou des bases
consensuelles consortiaux la
consensualité d'accord on s'est attaché
à faire ça bon plutôt que de déposer un
certain nombre de critères qui étaient
plus ou moins légaux et donc dans le
cadre de cette démarche consensuelle
on a convenu de fixer la date limite
2 avec la date limite pour se mettra pas
la date limite pour prendre la liste des
candidats au 31 décembre 2010
2010 c'est le premier point deuxième
limite recettes à fixer c'est que les
candidats devaient être à jour de leur
cotisation
enfin avant de les agresser qui manque
dans la zone dans le journal au 27 août
2010 8
la difficulté sur ce point est venue du
fait que certains membres ont cotisé
welmant le 27 le 27 août en disant qu on
se mit à djoko pour la période du 1017
est donc ce n'était pas jour pour la
période 2015 et 2000 2014 et vous n'y
aviez pas pensé auparavant
tout cet aspect pouvait apparaître
brusquement beaulaincourt cet aspect cet
aspect a été traité puisque mais c'est
une des parties a indiqué que non de la
mesure vous n'êtes pas à jour de
cotisation de 2004 ne peut pas voter ou
et c'est là où finalement la dimension
consensuel cesse d'être et que d'exister
puisque à ce moment là pour bien tenu
compte des exigences de la loi
oui quelques étages et une cotisation à
2017 année affecté ses cotisations en
2010 est pas aux fusées sa présence sur
la liste ce d'autant plus que les
statuts du mime ne prévoit pas de
sanction pour vis-à-vis des membres
c'est ce que vous dites à la miroite
vous dites que dans les statuts et
règlements de cette association
politique il n'ya rien qui concerne la
possible les modalités de rentrer au
sein du mit et surtout d'en sortir
nous aussi nous présenter dans une pose
surtout les sanctions concernant un
membre et pajot de ses cotisations
il ya matière il n'y a pas de sanction
il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas
de mesures prévues concernant le défaut
de règlement des cotisations de ceux
prévus et puis le conseil
d'administration n'a pas plus de
décisions concernant ces exclusions non
voyons déjà vous avez un petit problème
la géographie de ce collège et
deuxièmement cette liste que nous avions
communiqué à tous les autres candidats
cela nous fait observer que sur cette
liste il manquait des noms de manquer
des noms de personnes qui étaient à jour
des cotisations
d'après affirmation est là parce qu'il
ya un point centralisateur pour la
cotisation
écoutez je n'ai pas l'âge points 12-6 à
l'étape
ouais et ces gens là disent qu'ils sont
à jour des cotisations il présente des
bulletins d'adhésion avec âge avec des
vignettes qui témoignent du fait qu'ils
pourraient être à jour cela dit et c'est
là où les difficultés apparaissent et
que finalement il faut trouver la
correspondance entre cette liste là est
celle qui est transmise au conseil
national des partis politiques
oui parce qu'il va le rappeler à la mire
watts dans la structuration du mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais il ya des
comités patriotes qui qui agissent sur
des sommes de très localisés et ses
comités patriotes peuvent recevoir ou
non l'adhésion des membres à
confectionner oui voilà donc
donc en fait voyez que c'est le problème
qui s'est posé à auch où le problème
d'été de la liste est menée sur la liste
donc nous allons rajouter ceux ci nous
avait été communiquée par
les partisans qui disait que nous étions
à jour mais finalement laura 4 leur
adhésion était disputée on obtient le
fait qu'ils avaient et les vignettes et
donc la veille levé de l'élection n'a
rencontré un peu tout le monde
j'ai dit si c'est notamment est
notamment l'une des parties et nous
avons très tard le soir jusqu'à pâques
est leur fait le point sur la liste
cette liste ne posait problème comme on
trouve personne ouais mais trop de
personnes ou même deux personnes c'est
suffisant pour une pour avoir une
majorité et ses trente personnes c'est
cette perception fait l'objet d'un
examen à la lumière des listes
communiquées au conseil national à paris
et depuis 2013 on a pointé cette c30 non
on trouve depuis 2013 si j'avais été ou
non un moment ou un autre mission la
liste nationale ouais on en a trouvé que
8 ce qui explique et amélie tease pour
22 et saab vendue effectivement enfin
donné satisfaction à l'autre partie mais
le problème a sur ce point n'est pas un
problème
j'allais dire impossible à gérer qui
s'opposaient à ce moment là mais dans la
mesure où ils ont des vignettes et
commercialisation qui sont à jour une
simple simple démarche judiciaire doit
permettre de rétablir la réalité une
simple démarche judiciaire c'est-à-dire
que vous aurez recours à la justice pour
rétablir officiellement cette liste du
collège électoral
écoutez pour l'instant j'en sais rien il
faut que je discute avec les uns les
autres
mais si l'établissement de cette liste
sur la base des consensus
ça a l'air compliqué et que ce processus
ce consensus est remis en cause
différentes étapes on aura du mal à
avoir liste fondu sous un consensus réel
lorsque lorsque vous avez vu que ces
points des hawks crispation prenait de
l'importance entre jeudi soir et
vendredi 18 au moment de la tenue de
l'assemblée générale
est-ce qu'il n'aurait pas mieux valu
reporter l'assemblée générale c'est une
question qu'on peut se poser cela dit
j'ai pas senti cette réalité soit
infesté de la sorte puisque je vous dis
que la veille encore le débat ne portait
que sion à peu près 30 noms d'oncles
cette réalité ne se posait pas en ces
termes
mais alors pour vous ce lundi matin
c'est à dire un peu plus de 48 heures
après les faits vous avez au moins une
certitude à la miroite en tant
qu'administrateur de ce dossier c'est
que si vendredi soir certains contours
était floue aujourd'hui il existe un
véritable socle pour mieux préparer la
future assemblée générale qui tôt ou
tard se tiendra oui c'était de capazoo
moment où les sujets de crispation sont
identifiés
quel les difficultés sont elles aussi
identifié il devient plus facile
d'apporter des réponses
alors qu'au début tout début nous
partions d'une feuille blanche
oui un cran menace de porter plainte
contre vous l'autre parle de vous
récusez personne n'est content est ce
que vous allez me what
dans ce dossier vous avez envie de vous
retirer à cause du bruit ambiant noté
moi j'ai l'habitude de considérer que
lorsque les éléphants se battent c'est
l'herbe qui en pâtit oui donc dans ce
contexte delachaux pas étonné parce que
il faut développer les arguments d'un
côté comme de l'autre mais la réalité je
pense va s'imposer d'elle-même
l'habitude de gérer ce genre de deux
conflits dans votre métier ce genre de
litiges au sein d'associations ce qui
est plus délicat c'est parce que c'est
politique
je crois que compte tenu de la
personnalité des personnes impliquées je
pense que la politique juridique là sont
en opposition le juridique c'est d'un
instrument
qu'on utilise au service d'objectifs
politiques c'est clair moi je n'entends
pas aller sur le terrain politique sur
le terrain technique et sur le terrain
technique il ya des difficultés qu'on
doit pouvoir surmonter sont bas s'il n'y
a pas de problème là insurmontable et
des difficultés qu'on rencontre de
toutes les associations la future
assemblée générale puisqu'il en aura il
y en aura une
ce sera dans au minimum combien de temps
si vous avez recours à la justice pour
ceux déjà dit dans des recoins je suis
je dis à mon avis la solution aussi le
consensus n'arrive pas à s'établir ce
qui me paraît un peu compliquée
puisqu'il peut être remis en cause à
tout moment oui je vais avait de
l'assemblée si ce consensus n'est pas si
on les prend place il va falloir
effectivement à mon avis roucou et à
l'arbitrage de la justice on n'aurait
pas contents pour moi voire plusieurs
mois puisque de la mesure où vous avez
des candidats qui disent je suis inscrit
j'ai les bulletins j'ai un certain
nombre de pièces d'établissement qualité
de me faudra chercher la preuve de leur
cotisation les circonstances dans
lesquelles ces cotisations étaient
comptabilisés au siège
merci ce que le point quelques semaines
merci à la droite d'avoir été avec nous
ce matin dans son caddie on rappelle que
vous êtes l'administrateur provisoire
dans ce dossier de l'assemblée générale
du mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais bonne journée
[Musique]